do you think most girls are objective or
do you think they think they're hotter
than they are or do they underrate
themselves go around personally I think
it depends on the person because growing
up I'm obviously not skinny hi everyone
I'm not skinny so growing up I was never
the be standard for anyone so like all
my friends were getting chatted out by
people blah blah blah blah and I was
just the other one you know so like I
never really thought of myself as an
attractive person like I would never
call myself anything more than a thought
but now like I didn't really care about
what anyone thinks about me like I've
grown into myself and I've I've I'm
comfortable with who I am now that like
even if I you guys call me delusional or
whatever I think I'm not a 10 let's not
go that far but like definitely an eight
per so like whether you guys think I am
or not that's got nothing to do with her